they're the two men pursued by a u.s
justice system for what it calls a
litany of heinous and barbaric crimes
alexander cote and el-shafi al-shaikh
were two of the isis group
dubbed the beatles it was no term of
affection
hostages recognized their british
accents and their part in a group
that tortured prisoners and beheaded
them on camera
for propaganda videos it was the same
group that included muhammad emwazi
notoriously dubbed jihadi john he was
assassinated by u.s military forces in
2015.
a fourth member of the gang has been
jailed in turkey
coty and l sheikh were interviewed by
sky news
in custody in iraq ruthless yet
remorseless
you have nothing to say to families that
would just lost their husbands who were
actually doing aid work
not specifically no i don't have
anything to say to them the piers
arrival
in the united states to face prosecution
comes after they were stripped of their
british nationality
the uk handed over evidence it had
gathered to the americans
after the u.s agreed not to pursue the
death penalty
today's announcement is the result of
many years of hard work in the pursuit
of justice for these americans
we have been inspired by their memories
and moved by the determination
and grit of their families
families which will never rest until
justice is done
to them i say this neither will
we an eight-year legal pursuit of a
prosecution
has been welcomed by families of those
who were killed
hopefully these men will implicate
others and give us
information about where the remains of
our children are
and many many innocents
the british victims as well as innocent
people in syria david haynes was a
victim of isis
the british aid worker killed in 2014.
his brother mike called the latest
developments a big win
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo
tweeted we welcome the transfer of the
isis beatles to the united states
to stand trial on a court of law the
united states will not rest until these
alleged terrorists
are held accountable for their crimes
and justice is delivered
to their victims families the two men
deny the charges against them
in the past they've claimed their
involvement in isis was limited to
ransom negotiations
between hostages and their families and
government
but the indictment they face here ties
them into a wider charge of
hostage-taking
and murder it cites one example in 2014
of when they took five european hostages
to witness the execution of a syrian
prisoner
and turn to the europeans and said
you're next
they were two of america's most wanted
now safely delivered